Kevin Young
“Thataway”
Was walking. Was
walking
& then waiting
for a train,
the 12:40
to take us thataway.
(I got there early.)
Wasn’t a train
exactly but a chariot
or the Crescent Limited come
to carry me
some
home I didn’t yet know.
There were those
of us not ready
till good
Jim swung from a tree
& the white folks crowded
the souvenir photo’s frame—
let his body blacken,
the extremities
shorn—
not shed,
but skimmed off
so close it can be shaving
almost.
An ear
in a pocket, on a shelf,
a warning where a book
could go.
So
I got there early.
See now, it was morning
a cold snap,
first frost
which comes even here
& kills the worms
out the deer.
You can
hunt him then
but we never did want,
after, no trophy
crowned down
from a wall, watching—
just a meal,
what
we might make last till spring.
There are ways
of keeping a thing.
Then there are ways
of leaving, & also the one way.
That
we didn’t want.
I got there early.
Luggage less sturdy
(cardboard,
striped, black)
than my hat.
Shoebox of what I shan’t say,
lunch on my lap.
The noise the rails made
even before the train.
A giant stomach growling.
A bowed belly.
I did
not pray.
I got there
early.
It was not
no wish, but a way.